what's going on guys this is rob and
this is the setup that i'm actually
going to be using for saturday hence the
cables and stuff that are kind of
running everywhere but we're going to be
using it on saturday for the live
reactions for d23 the marvel studios
panel i'm so excited for that but in the
interim i figured why not use this setup
to react to the newest black atom
trailer which is like just came out
something like 30 minutes ago a little
late to the party kind of not really but
uh let's jump into it
and let's see what this trailer has to
offer right hopefully it's not a repeat
of the footage that we've seen before
but uh we'll find out
my son sacrificed his life to save me
yeah i've seen this before
are not a gift
but a curse
i mean not really because he's pretty
badass out of rage
i'd be like these powers are awesome
i love this scene i thought it was gonna
be one of the best scenes in the whole
movie
god i love this soundtrack this loose
cannon needs to be locked down
before innocent people start getting
hurt straight up out of iron man he's
been asleep
if you find us a cell that can hold him
we'll take care of the rest who's on the
team
i'm so excited amanda wallace on this
passport we don't need passports
you're the justice society
jsa i'm so excited that's a jfk i mean
we've for the most part seen this stuff
i don't really see anything new we're
here to negotiate your peaceful
surrender
nor do i surrender
here we go
this is awesome
wow
boom
i'm so excited for that
oh my god this movie's gonna be so great
you didn't come here to seek justice
i'm more excited for dr faith than
anything else
[Music]
i never said i was a
[Music]
believe hero are not worthy
but fate does not make mistakes
god it's gonna be nuts
[Music]
that fight scene looks like it's gonna
be insane but oh no whoa
okay that's gotta be etrigan
god that looks so cool
okay that's gotta be etrigan
there's no way that's anybody other than
etrigan and here's here's the reason why
but i don't think there's any more
scenes
okay yeah there's no more scenes okay
so that's gotta be etrigan right i know
a lot of people probably gonna say
that's trigen there's no way that's
trigon right like here's the thing try
again this guy is he's like a thanos in
the dc universe right i mean there's a
lot of people that are equivalent to him
right so like the specter people like
that like when they show up in terms of
significance like it's a big deal when
they arrive but when it comes to
somebody like try again he's not a guy
that you just throw into a black adam
movie now it's entirely possible one of
others is just
i don't know what they have going on
over there but it's entirely possible
they took somebody it's huge's dragon
and they put him in a black adam film
the reality of this is that if they were
to do that right it would be like it
would be the equivalent of the marvel
cinematic universe putting thanos in as
the villain of like a thor film and it'd
be cool to see but like he's bigger than
that and you would expect him to be
treated bigger than that and that's how
trigon is right whenever dragon shows up
this guy's at a whole different level of
power i mean literally it's like the end
times when this guy shows up when this
guy appears that's it right like pretty
much everybody's gonna die that's how
you know things are popping off only the
most powerful of beings in dc comics are
powerful enough to take this guy on when
it comes to something like that that's
kind of what you expect to see right but
it makes more sense to me that it would
be etrigan so etrigan is basically a guy
named jason blood and in fact we might
do a video on him over at comics
explained explaining his character but
etrigan is a guy named jason blood and
the idea behind etrigan is it's
literally jason who turns into him right
he says gone gone the form of man
arrives the demon etregon and the other
thing about it if they really want to
kind of maintain that comedic humor this
etrigon rhymes everything when he talks
but he's ridiculously powerful he's the
perfect kind of villain to have for like
a black adam film and the jsa because he
is comparable in power to pretty much
everybody there it would take really all
of them unifying as a team especially
including black adam in order to defeat
him but with somebody like like trigon
not a chance no way that's trigger
there's no no i don't i don't believe
that maybe it is and maybe warner
brothers will come out just for no other
reason than to cover my own backside
maybe it is
right and maybe warner brothers is
making it trigger in that film but if
i'm a betting man i'd say that it's
probably etrigan anyway guys let me know
who you think it is down in the comments
section thank you all for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace